hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my interview with noah kagan and we're
talking about the idea of goals and how
setting goals in the wrong way can
sometimes have the potential to kill
your motivation so i hope you enjoy the
clip so have you got a process that you
go through to set goals and i'm asking
selfishly because i guess you're
familiar with
the jason freed and dhh approach to
goals like the whole base camp spiel
seems to be that we don't really like
setting goals goals are arbitrary why
would you bother
taking this number that you've made up
out of thin air why would you take that
seriously and instead they seem to say
that it's more about just focusing on
just trying to make a good product and
have fun while you're doing it and serve
the community and stuff
and i find that i resonate with that
quite a lot and so when it comes to i've
got this business mentor who always
encourages me to set numerical goals for
my youtube channel and i always feel
that uh what's the point why my goal is
to hit a million subscribers by 2020.
like it's
it seems very arbitrary how do you think
about goal setting because i'm i'm
really not sure on this front
okay so you're where are you in the uk
right now i'm in cambridge
you're in cambridge it just sounds so
cool when you say it man and if you were
gonna if i was gonna say
ali go to france
how would you figure that how to get to
france just like directionally oh i'd go
on google maps and figure it out
okay so i think what the 37 signals guys
are saying is let's say you're in
america and you want to get to mexico
they're like just drive south and
eventually mexico's down there and if if
you don't hit it just keep going south
until you do
and so
i've observed three systems of setting
goals
and i think each of them can work
so i think there's the object-oriented
goal which is what is my objective so i
want a million subscribers so for
appsumo our company we have a revenue
goal we want to get extra millions of
dollars in revenue this year very
objective and you'd have sometimes have
to have a destination
mexico revenue
so then i think there are processes i
think there are progress goals so a
progress goal
is so another example is like my mailing
list so like sendfox.com my mailing list
i don't care if i get one and what's
important about goals is they have to
matter to you
so a progress goal is i don't care if i
get one new active subscriber a month or
a thousand it doesn't change for me the
value
so a progress goal to me is it
progressing and i get five i'm happy if
it's negative i'm not and so that's a
progress goal and the last one is the
system goal so a system goal is i'm
gonna go to the gym three times a week
that's it that's my system there's not a
progress but i will be there three times
a week and so i think each of those
goals work in different scenarios and
different things so it's i don't i
wouldn't say absolutely that third
sentence was wrong i think in business
i think you have to know how things are
performing or progressing so we
generally do
our whole system in there we call it a
gmo but i think there's other goals
where you don't want to have that
because for me like youtube if right now
i'm at fifty thousand and if i said i
want a hundred thousand honestly it
would kill my motivation
it and i don't care if i get a hundred
thousand or if i get fifty one thousand
i'm just enjoying what i'm doing so it's
more of like all right i want to put out
three videos a week or two videos
whatever that is and each one is a
different tool at a different time
okay yeah that makes sense i think
that's the
system's goal is very much how i think
about my youtube channel that the only
thing we're aiming for is to get one
video out a week or two or three
depending on the week and if we can make
these videos a bit better over time if
the numbers can be trending in the right
direction
then that's all that really matters and
i don't really have a sort of subscriber
count goal because as you said i think
it would take a lot of the fun out of it
because i feel like if i did set out to
get a million subscribers by 2021 i'd be
doing things that prioritize getting
views and that might not necessarily be
the same stuff as what i'm interested in
so for example if that was a goal i
wouldn't do any books about fiction
i wouldn't do any videos about fiction
books because it doesn't tie in with
that particular goal but i guess
i do have goals in other domains like
for example
if i'm setting out to do like a new
business venture or something i have
this bar in my head that i want this
thing to make at least 500 a month and i
do what it takes for it to make at least
500 a month and beyond that if it makes
1000 2000 at that point i don't really
care provided it hits that 500 a month
thing
and i think i suppose that's to the
extent to which i have that sort of goal
yeah i think that's great man i'll tell
you for me when i launched my podcast
three years ago i went i set a goal
before i really do anything and i think
what's really important and this is
really important it's really easy to get
what you want
but it's hard to know what you want
i'll say it again and i'll say it the
opposite way it's really hard to know
what you want
but it's really easy to get it when you
know it
i believe every single person out there
that's watching and listening i believe
in every single person here can do it
but i think we need to spend more time
thinking about what we actually really
want
because then you're like like one year
for appsumo i wanted a million email
subscribers and and i i knew in my heart
i was like i don't give a [ __ ]
and so i would spend more time exploring
what do we really want journaling
writing thinking talking
and the second thing
so in terms of that is that like i told
you my podcast i wanted a hundred
thousand downloads an episode
and by the end of the year i got thirty
thousand downloads an episode
and so
i quit
really oh
i quit
i gave up because i wasn't at a hundred
thousand
and about seven months later i said i
really enjoyed the podcast but because i
put that pressure on the goal
it killed the motivation for it and so
it's not to say not to have that
so i started up again about seven to
nine months later
my downloads now are at 10 000 an
episode
i would beg for 30 000.
and i changed my goal to say just put
out one episode that you love a week
and now i don't look at my stats
and i love doing the show
i love it gave me the opportunity to
hang out with owen and with you and talk
to the audience and share this stuff
that i know fulfills me
and so i think goal setting could be
dangerous
because guess what 30 000 is actually a
top show
but now at 10 000 i'm just as satisfied
but if i would have just stayed
consistent and it adjusted my
expectations
maybe it would be a fifty thousand now
or it would have been at a hundred
thousand
i think what we imagine we don't realize
how long this is going to go on for we
didn't think like the shows are gonna be
going or the work like appsumo and sumo
group our company i did not think i'd be
doing this ten years later i thought i
would make three thousand dollars a
month and live on the beaches of
thailand nice
[Laughter]
so i think the point is find the things
that you could do for 10 years because i
said earlier the 10-year rule is true
yeah i remember are you familiar with
marquez brownlee the tech youtuber mkbhd
yeah a little bit what about him yeah so
he was he was on the y combinator
podcast for some reason and they were
interviewing him and and he was
basically talking about the 10-year rule
they asked him like what's the secret to
your success and he was like in in
fairness i don't know man just pick
something and work on it for 10 years
and then it's probably going to be
successful
i was like damn that's such good advice
just pick something anything and just
work on it for 10 years as people like
gary vaynerchuk would say it's all about
patience in the long term
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye